act of war i love the um i love the
players in war i love the philosophy of
war
so reading all of these kinds of books
and we
just before coming down here today i
took you to the rare book room to see
a first edition of machiavelli i've
really
i must say i've really taken my guests
to see the
the special collections and seen them as
deeply curious as you were seeing this
work
it really means something to you to see
these books
you said to me when we left the the
special collections you said you know
the most stolen items in the world are
books
they're most um they're almost um
priceless possessions because if you
think about it you know
a room without a book is like a body
without a soul
you know we have to um it's the only way
that we can connect the future with the
past
without that there's no way that we can
come with no way we can know about the
future
i know about the future know about
particularly
um the past or the presence you know
because when you think about
um history the value of history is not
necessarily
scientific but moral by liberating our
minds and
you know deepening our sympathies and
fortifying our will
we um we we can control um
pretty much history allows us to control
not society but ourself which is a much
more important thing
to do you know what i mean and it would
allow us to pretty much um
meet the future more so than foretell it
and
for that reason alone that we always
have to um in order to
the for the order to predict
the future we have to always look it
through the past because very rarely
does the
time is not repeat itself and it always
will repeat itself
i've heard a quote before in the book
that um
um we would be fools to think
historically that um
the past is us and funny clothes but the
past is us a funny clothes
and that's truly what it is that's
somebody that really said a really
profound statement but he misquote what
he was saying he must have been saying
it backwards because that's really what
the past was
it's just us in funny clothes in
different times that's really what it is
but you were saying you know